ist es endlich soweit ist dass jetzt
tatsächlich der endgültige beweis für
außerirdisches leben nachdem wir schon
so lange suchen wenn ja wäre dass
tatsächlich die wohl größte entdeckung
der mensch ein konkret geht es um eine
sehr mysteriöse probe die an der
internationalen raumstation iss gefunden
wurde ein russischer kosmonaut ist sich
ganz sicher dass diese bakterien aus dem
weltraum kommen um welche probe sich
genau handelt und ob sie tatsächlich die
suche nach außerirdischem leben mit
einem großen erfolg zu ende bringt jetzt
den krieg zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
diese nachricht ist einfach nur geil
zitat beim entnehmen von abstrichen sind
bakterien gefunden worden die während
des starts des moduls noch nicht dort
gewesen sind das hat der russische
kosmonaut antennen ablauf der
staatlichen nachrichtenagentur tass ende
oktober berichtet seine vermutung die
bakterien seien aus dem weltraum
richtung iss geflogen und hätten sich
dort niedergelassen gefunden wurde diese
probe nach starb lehrers angaben bei
einem weltraumspaziergang an der
außenseite der station
dies liegt wohl schon länger zurück doch
erst jetzt fanden sich in den laboren
auf der erde wohl die hinweise auf
diesen mysteriösen spuren bei den
untersuchungen kamen demnach heraus dass
sich darin bakterien befinden
die eben beim start des moduls noch
nicht vorhanden waren so starb lehrer
das bedeutet sie sind aus dem weltraum
gekommen und haben sich an der äußeren
oberfläche niedergelassen
sie werden bis jetzt untersucht und es
scheint dass sie keine gefahr darstellen
doch die analyse der proben ist noch
längst nicht abgeschlossen und das heißt
tatsächlich alles ist möglich
doch am wichtigsten ist jetzt vor allem
eine sache auszuschließen dass die
bakterien von der erde stammen denn
welche hinweise konkret auf
außerirdisches leben schließen lassen
darauf geht der kosmonaut in dem kurzen
bericht der nachrichtenagentur tass
nicht ein laut der russischen agentur
meldung vermuten die beteiligten
kosmonauten jedenfalls dass die
mysteriösen bakterien- wohl drei jahre
lang im weltraum zu gebracht haben
müssen
das heißt also konkret in einem
luftleeren raum mit sagenhaften
temperaturschwankungen die von -150 bis
plus 150 grad celsius reichen
dennoch wäre eine irdische kontamination
auch eben sehr gut denkbar denn wir
haben ja schon öfter darüber berichtet
mikroorganismen sind sehr viel robuster
als man vielleicht denken mag selbst die
extremsten bedingungen egal ob auf der
erde oder im weltraum scheinen vielen
bakterien nichts auszumachen bärtierchen
zum beispiel sind so gut wie
unzerstörbar sie können unter extrem
lebensfeindlichen bedingungen überleben
realistisch gesehen heißt das wohl dass
die mysteriöse bakterien probe mikroben
aus der erdatmosphäre enthält aber und
das ist das spannende wenn bagdad
eben von der erde unter diesen
bedingungen dort existieren können dann
können auch bakterien von anderen
planeten so durch den weltraum reisen
und das leben im universum von einem zum
nächsten sternensystem tragen weltraum
staub bewegt sich sehr schnell und so
ist es nicht unrealistisch dass mikroben
aus anderen sternensystem mit ihm reisen
manche acto biologen und biologin gehen
davon aus dass genau durch diesen
prozess auch das leben auf der erde
entstanden es ist aber eben ursprünglich
ganz anders wo aus der galaxie stammt
von der nasa jedenfalls gibt es bisher
noch keine offizielle stellungnahme
fest steht jedoch dass sich die suche
nach außerirdischem leben immer weiter
zuspitze den nächsten 20 jahren so
schätzt die nasa werden wir
außerirdisches leben finden wenn er kein
video zu diesem thema also wenn er sich
verpassen wollte und auch zu allen
anderen themen dann wird mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke nur dann verpasst
er kein video hier geht es weiter mit
dafür draufklicken aliens können wir sie
leichter finden dafür gibt es nämlich
eine menge gründe also ansonsten bis
dahin bleibt dann